[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm going to tell
you the true reason why Rhaegar led Sir
Arthur Dayne at the Tower of joy as
you'll know near the end of Robert's
rebellion he and Sir Gerald were
stationed to guard the Tower of joy by
Prince Rhaegar himself when Lord Eddard
Stark of Winterfell arises bannermen
including Lord Howland Reed in order to
rescue in a start day encircled
Hightower prevent the north man from
entering the tower peacefully then is
shown to be cordial twittered refuses to
tell me why exactly the now-deceased
Rhaegar wanted them to remain there or
the very bowels of Eddard sister knowing
there's no alternative Dana and Sir
Gerald fight a Northman to hold the
tower Gerald is quickly killed by Lord
Eddard in the melee but he easily holds
his own against Norman cutting down most
of them his two sorts living just him in
a dirt as brainwashes them deal he
observes that Dain is a better swordsman
in his father the three-eyed Raven
corrects him far better then eventually
disarms Eddard but as he moves to strike
him down Howland Reed who had been
wounded earlier in the battle
sneaks up behind Dain and stabs him in
the back of the neck he's badly wounded
by the attack and falls to his knees
holding on to his sword for a few
seconds before dropping it as his
strength fades the two look at each
other as air picks up dawn seeming
ashamed of how he gets right although in
agony Dayne seems accepting of his fate
he had done his duty to the last letter
delivers the final blow killing the
legendary sorted mourning and sparing
him from a slower death in my opinion
protecting Rhaegar son the future King
was not the only duty rag arrest of dane
who is regarded by many as the greatest
knight to have ever lived
Dane was a legendary Knight and one of
the finest men to have joined the
Kingsguard probably rivaled only by
servers and Sonny
Danes reputation was such that when
people remembered him it was with a
claim Dane is remembered as the greatest
night of his generation not only martial
skill but in value and virtue as at your
night even servers Anselmi a living
legend in his own right though the Dane
surpassed himself in all respects sir
bar stand Jaime Lannister Eliminator
start we're all in veneration of Dain
and recalling me nothing less than
complete reverence
Jamie tells Loras Tyrell a member of the
Kingsguard in the books that Dane could
have slain all five of you with his left
hand while he was taking a piss with
right anyways why was a Dane who's left
at the Tower of joy he was the greatest
warrior of his generation probably every
mistress so why leave him there
and he by himself could have even
changed the course of the Battle of the
Trident as Sir Gerald pointing out
himself
truth be told a and even though far
superior than any other fighter he could
not have changed the course of the
battle by killing endless amount of
enemies but they in would have guarded
his prints and hid Robert come across
Dane the battle would have probably
ended much different Rhaegar would not
have been killed and the leader of the
rebels would have died why leave the
best fighter in Westeros editar oh joy
yes to protect his son John but by Dane
in particular Dane who would have
protected Rhaegar during the Battle of
the Trident and he was possibly the only
one who could have defeated Robert
Baratheon in a fight well in my opinion
is because Danes duty was not only to
protect John but to adopt him as well
Targaryen escape their unique traits
with silver hair being the most
prominent one and the middle Targaryen
genes successive to star genes Rhaegar
could not risk it and that's why it had
to be Dane who'd been John as his own
and not someone else for example men
it's coming for Danes to look like the
Garren's their hair usually being silver
and ice violet had John inherited his
father's looking at these matters nobody
would have ever suspected that son of
Sir Arthur Dayne was not actually
attained by a Targaryen the day and
shared the same features as Targaryen
the Danes here has been described as
pale blond dark and silver the Danes
also have black blue or purple eyes
seven if John did turn out to look as a
Targaryen he would have easily been
passed as a Dane however had John
inherited his father's traits with his
alleged father being Ned both John and
Ned would have probably been killed as
John could not possibly pass as a stark
Ned could not offend John against Robert
the only way Ned could have saved John
in that case would have been by lying
that John's murder was a Charlaine with
whom he was rumored to have an affair a
lie which Ned probably would not tell
considering how vulnerable Ned was and
how much he respected a shower
sohe John looks like a Targaryen both
Ned and John would have been long gone
chewing that case Robert would give me
the chance to handle him a baby
Targaryen so he would kill it
but men would fight and go in a
rebellion before doing that so both of
them would have been killed had John
inherited his fighters look the only
person who could have passed John as his
own no matter his hair was black brown
or silver was Dain
that's what Rhaegar knew and that's why
dane could not let Ned in the tower
Rhaegar command Dayne to protect an
adoption and pass him as his own and
Dane the finest knight of the Kingsguard
did his best obey the commands of his
Prince and best friend and as always I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace